hello and welcome to this video papua 29
yep played this guy a couple of times
with good results but absurd and no not
be five please the answer and we got a
london system here this line is salmon
yeah known to be good for black for a
very long time a bit surprising that and
I get it on the board but it still
happens yeah black already has a slight
advantage in this position it's nothing
I'm too dramatic but throw up quite nice
mmm yeah looks do you one I don't know
usually you go to see one so that you
have Bishop e2 d1c to later we will see
if this is having le any relevance no
might might have so what do you see come
doing him maybe shooting for a quickie
for my dears in 97 96 98 4 and wins the
thing is he will probably go a form
before I'm able to do that so probably I
want to develop first
and maybe just canceling hmm okay i was
thinking 95 but sure you can play Knight
h2 so what about this night if four is
even interesting here yeah i think i'm
going to go into play for for the night
over 24 yeah it was clear that he was
shooting for a 34 it makes us and makes
us some of his pieces look really weird
the night h2 in particular let's see how
to play this
night a 410 why not yeah I can take on
any form play five it's an excellent for
black makes this bishop on you to look
really weird
yeah I think he has to go Bishop e3
thats only move that still seems
playable yeah yeah yeah I've already had
to do that ok now i was thinking i can
take and place III lamb the main danger
is to screw it up on time so let's play
quickly the position is excellent I
cannot take this and if you place ok I
can take on b2 now if I like oh yeah I
think I'll do that huh only maybe it's
God look see one hmm
and 95 is also just fine right Knight to
c4 cannot be so bad
okay Bishop hmm Bishop c5 it's not
totally convincing actually okay but I
have to play cannot spend even more time
here now that seems winning though check
check yeah that seems winning now that
was a really bad position for white for
quite a bit like quite recent times yeah
I'm surprised that people still play
into this kind of line as it is so I
thought pretty commonly no one that leg
is just better him we black has this
disadvantage in space on the queenside
the open a file is useful and them and
you have very easy plans this isn't
further in accuracy you have to probably
play something like this III Bishop f5
Luke see one that's actually in precise
III that's before so let's say we start
with this Bishop and five III h six
assured me to something like this is
serve is one white quite often wants to
do yeah maybe casuals first I don't know
something like that to to preempt this
regrouping like it's better but this is
just how it is yeah so he tried this
which isn't which isn't so terrible i
think but here i think just 95 and this
sir era i still rather be black but this
is probably nothing nothing special no i
think black has a little bit of an
advantage due to the queen sized space
edge but he scurries getty for and
probably and it's a bit strange to
prepare it like that but maybe
yeah maybe playable okay I went here and
I could have played this already mmm
what's a good move by the engine check
like it's in fantastic shape as the
white can never move the e pawn due to
93 this would be a fun way to Toulouse
immediately I could have played that now
this this is a check oh it's so pretty
and pretty awful then something i have
just have fantastic pressure no but this
is also what so pretty bad okay yeah i
could have taken already and play play
you five or bishop h form ok anyway but
this is a good position anyway but this
is helping me i'm pretty sure this this
now this nd5 yeah this is a good
continuation the answer actually wants
to do this and says this wins even more
convincingly yeah which is definitely
true now that i look at it no you you
will you will win the house am through
pretty pretty nice with those passes and
whites pieces are complete mess they
don't do anything upon so just promote
but this is also very good gets minus
two yeah i could have taken 1 b 2 here I
let saving strong Gaia that's probably
even stronger this is not bad he should
have taken here and now play rooks it to
according to the comp it is also clearly
better from blank
yeah the thing is All Blacks pieces are
active they all make some sense well
those pieces are not well placed and his
bones are weak a 3 4 and so on now this
whatever check lost chatted material
immediately yeah somehow I've always
fare well against the sky works
sometimes it works that where you have
opponents where you simply don't play
your best ok well thanks for watching